what up guys goes in for anime uproar
and today we're going to animate North
and we're actually about to drop this
Levi video right here and then we're
going to head out slide the ad guys it's
been a year years since we started
making these videos actually showing our
faces on the screen and we've come a
long way from less than a thousand subs
to now I already know what it is right
now like twelve thousand five hundred
seven hundred so it's been amazing
here we are guys anime North oh man it
still bright outside ah but is up baby
this is a new anime afro shirts
prototype man turn around man
around look at what's this guy brought
guys they said it was impossible to take
this huge flag in the car for an hour
and a half drive it said you couldn't do
it but we did the impossible we do with
the impossible we see the invisible they
expand row row fight the Paola
[Music]
social media guys check it out and be my
best girl
Amelia best girls oh yeah oh my god oh
my god oh man what up guys good let's go
again you got a hold that what ride this
works out well
[Music]
and I'm back signing up for the panel
hold that up better back analyst powers
activate
here we are guys people recognizing the
amazing iconic flag roll all denied the
power babe some of these
you know I kill a kill never looked so
good
who
who to go
Boop
and I step out right there
don't worry about it Cowboys be part
I have to show you guys a few see you on
par with the food look at that oh my god
and the ninetails thoughts has never
looked so - no one can be valid these
two
Emilia hand
you can only keep your Bible just one if
you want it - why - oh yeah if you want
just immunity is just getting really and
I'm pleased now there's a queue one the
other one and you're like who's round
but it's not complete ban guys our on a
mission to find three take a all-day
anime
yes high-five whoo looky come to animate
north and watch anime
cool air power fret not
Kevin Bacon I love the response we're
getting from this flag people keep dying
at the rate of higher ban higher hi
oh we're going to buy a body pillow our
first buddy a collective body photo we
could share one that'll people w/e
that's weird but so right yeah I know it
Superman there's nog ISA
still on the hunt for great
like that alright so well we sudden we
do is we raise our flag and then prig
goes how to find them
anyone in the freaking place okay first
of all at all [ __ ]
ready Alice all jammer32 go they were
like I wanted to catch it and then you
guys just knock off behind us
[Applause]
alright guys the break went to launch
one piece there's a lumpy handle and you
know Briggs is all over it and you know
we'd be we'd be hearing some mad
spoilers but we're like so we're going
to be up later with him and back as well
in the meantime go Phil democracy I got
I'm going to be bragging I pretty much
caught someone's with Briggs so yeah we
got filmer back alone we've known max
then pretty much right after enemy North
last year yeah so it's going to involve
I'm sick or online friendship is going
to blow by RL bad I are out front now I
will eat you with Cupid
Oh
all right this is for you and uncle
forward looks driver we're going to film
it
it's so guys you can decide yogi on the
show buddy put your name miss Mason
Mason and then we're going to discover
what we could hear it
we had to quality we would not die so
then we decided for these two girls you
have a lot what are you yeah okay
we're together we're brothers somebody
changed man give em up and try the show
thank you
how do you feel man I feel then Nathan I
feel good
a little dirty guys epic attack on Titan
are dinosaurs bored right over here
155 but I would get it because one punch
man and of course more
anamarie cons what dream on we're going
to meet up with Mac food and the
question is who what female characters
to go before us forever
yeah we have a tip that he's calling of
the chick again so we'll be maka monkish
cook from killa kill or will it be I
hope to god Reb Roman in the rain I'm
still in the rain since the Pokemon go
video
it's telling Anna Mac the other day that
second first recognize me from the
Pokemon goal videos and real life which
was cool job and those videos were fun
while they lasted one without at the
cool cosplay right back this wrong
servile yes laying out the green tape so
Briggs actually knows what Mack is play
softly on Bobby's I guess nice they get
ruined the surprise
look Ross Hiroshi oh my god that's looks
good on a Leo
I don't know where anything is going
amazing amazing job rock salt applies to
our flies - where's your kimono how
we're preparing for preparedness item
cleansing now
you're not ready for this we live here
me Mac yet either this is first time
oh there is what the hell
whoo what are you dress sighs Paul man
there's back Victor Maximus everyone I
ain't doing octopus stylish scarf I
don't know why I assumed he would be
shorter but he is not know Allah know we
have Michelle of course we do and hike
back dear-dear line so what is that
costume yeah golden Macha bunker scoop
like that hair man like yeah let's get a
full body body shot of mac feeling super
comfortable in that
about an AI I know right I don't know
it's just like we got another over a lot
of broads or something look at this this
is great laser
now we're just trying to find place to
eat or waiting 40 minutes seen at this
place I forgot was called Plaza
milestone the food of champion perfect
just because just because I know he's
gonna hate it
by the time when I got to risk often not
look like an insane yeah I'll be
teaching about ahead and make my editor
you know business together
good par anything yeah you guys I think
our parents actually cited the editor
friends together I've known in my entire
life I just met this yes
if he's alright
Oh Oh No
of course they're coming getting John
the hand that's like my aspiration
you guys with it
there we go
that's not especially worn right there
Bruno wearing his now
[Applause]
you're the only one back there now this
one and AH we're very interested and I
know what what the back says their
company their only uncomfy if you just
landed all right nothing I mean both of
our subscribers should have that issue
but there we go we have three nine nine
oh yeah like without special deal now
for the 39 ice cold drinks activate
actively that's going to be on animated
philosophy so check it out Sunday I'll
be there I'll be there cheering them on
I'm sure you Mon got a boiler in their
production gunner okay that's not good
work they see me rollin they hatin
patrolling tryna catch me ridin dirty
because I do that guys we have their two
beds we have a nice room here at the
hotel quite the setup what's wrong with
your anime you to Bree gets pinned
Hilton all that stuff it's right the
barge you're not counting on an anime
money to pay for it as long as you're
paying with your own money
do whatever you want that's right of the
life that we got right now it's like a
Brahms 7:00 p.m. we were not at the con
all day and we got some really cool
stuff which I can't wait to show you
guys hey I made some impulse purchases
I'm not gonna lie
yeah we were as a consequence eleven you
screw it up it
yeah we're going back again
NAT please I'm paid to anime North here
the header I've lost balance Matt I'm
here to learn about philosophy and peace
Martin stuff so we have three experts
including our whole and Animax big
turnout the biggest according to Max and
aggressively what I really been
concerned about satisfying as I did my
PhD I really looked at a living sense of
political and philosophical themes in
anime that is one thing that they rented
an anime for me mature anime especially
from Western cartoons
you've got an underlying messages the
use of anime and philosophy and now I'm
actually a lot of my brothers over there
building actually after pinch of my PhD
I brought in our YouTube channel with
them and try to get a novel publish the
console you know the traditional 95
roots does what okay by the way that
black over there is mine
and I was bringing it in they asked me
you know is this what a family is your
parents are not a problem
I said of course it is not being pompous
and bring the vodka panel because that
is the whole point of my philosophy the
inspiration the motivation motivation
which is largely they draw for unlocking
and coming up in my idol in life I
thought that's a great point and I think
that's something that I always bring up
because here we've been conditioned
maybe less so now with cartoons like
Archer and Bojack horseman but mostly in
Western society we've been conditioned
to think that cartoons of her kids right
therefore to entertain kids Saturday
morning cartoons right whereas animal
day for four times that of children show
like Pokemon for example we also have
materials they make anime for older
children young adult and for adults
right and my gateway anime in terms of
mature anime was definitely because I
had this Alliance myself and then I saw
death no because my brother over there
told me to you're not putting this in
the video
oh you don't mean he's like you got to
check this out and I watched like what
I'm so in the middle of the shoulders of
a lot to me and I just watched it in
Serbia I was there visiting family and I
am washed in there and I put liquid in
the liquid watch out like wow this is
really complex things you know like vs.
ll like this is odd just on cartoon so I
first hand how to learn Python you great
anime that this youngin business if they
actually take this stuff seriously
how does it feel how does it feel being
done he was how was the panel how do you
feel that also which was longer yeah
like you think we got Mecca everything
Sun converted yes oh yeah
guys look at this dude will prepare for
a schist
that will be coming out one of these
days thanks for watching guys and I mean
north was a blast we had so much fun
meeting all our anime YouTube friends it
was great and I look forward to next
year already can't wait to see how far
will be thanks for an awesome year and
until next time see us BAE's Cowboys
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]